[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be discussing the rather
dark topic of witch hunts diving deep
into how witch hunts and Witch Trials
have shaped the course of the Wizarding
worlds and our own history while the
World of Harry Potter may be filled with
wonder and awe it is not immune to the
Shadows that lurk in the human heart
just like in our own muggle history The
Wizarding World has faced its fair share
of witch hunts and unjust persecution
where fear and Prejudice have cast a
Sinister Veil over the lives of magical
beings but before we get started on the
fictional witch answered unfold within
the pages of Harry Potter I want to
First Take a look at the extensive
history of witch hunts in our own world
a phenomenon spanning multiple centuries
that claim the lives of a staggering 35
000 to 50 000 victims once we're done
covering the real cities that occurred
will segue into the Wizarding world's
version of witch hunts and see how they
differ what are witch hunts in the
annals of human history few events evoke
as much Fascination and Dread as the
dark and enigmatic phenomenon that our
witch hunts these chilling chapters in
our Collective past send shivers down
our spines as the fear and paranoia that
fueled them seem inconceivable in our
modern world yet to truly understand the
roots and complexities of witch hunts we
must embark on a Journey Through Time
exploring their Origins motivations and
the devastating consequences that befell
those accused of Witchcraft at their
core witch hunts were frenzied campaigns
that sought to identify persecute and
eliminate individuals believed to
possess Supernatural powers and consort
with dark Forces the accused were often
labeled as witches or Sorcerers seen as
agents of evil and malevolence witch
hunts took various forms throughout
history but they shared a Common Thread
the pervasive belief that witches posed
a threat to society and that their
eradication was a sacred Duty
the roots of which hands can be tracked
back to various ancient civilizations
where the fear of usurping powers and
the unknown fueled a belief in Magic and
Witchcraft in societies such as ancient
Egypt Mesopotamia and Greece practices
such as divination potions and spells
were prevalent forming the Bedrock of
magical Traditions but while these
ancient civilizations held a nuanced
view of magic with practitioners often
revered as wise individuals the seeds of
Suspicion and fear did eventually begin
to take root The Classical period Europe
and Beyond one of the most infamous
chapters in the history of witch hunts
unfolded During the period known as
early modern Europe aka the
post-medieval period which is between
the late 15th century to the late 18th
century at this time in Europe witch
hunts reached a fever pitch as societal
anxieties religious fervor misogyny and
power dynamics decided to create a
perfect storm of Hysteria and
persecution superstitious beliefs
blended with Christian teachings and
fears of Supernatural forces setting the
stage for a Relentless pursuit of those
believed to be witches the persecutions
were fueled by various cultural
political and religious factors the
Reformation with its fragmentation of
the Catholic church and Rise of
protestantism led to increased religious
tensions and divisions different
Christian denominations vied for power
and influence and accusations of
Witchcraft became a means to discredit
and eliminate Rivals moreover the
patriarchal societal structure of the
time exacerbated the persecution of
women women accused of being witches
were often marginalized impoverished or
independent challengingly prevailing
gender norms and threatening the
established power dynamics women who did
not conform to the expectations of their
communities were more vulnerable to
accusations a their perceived
Independence or unconventional Behavior
was seen as evidence of their connection
to dark Powers the methods employed
during witch hunts were cruel and
horrific accused individuals were
subjected to torture confessions who
often coerced and trials were far from
Fair
common proofs of Witchcraft included
physical marks such as birth marks or
moles believed to be witch's marks
supernatural abilities like the ability
to float or shape-shift and even the
testimony of other accused witches
obtained under torture
Salem Witch Trials but which trials
certainly weren't exclusive to Europe in
the Americas the infamous Salem witch
trials unfolded in colonial
Massachusetts leaving an indelible mark
on American history before I dive into
the Salem Witch Trials too much I'd like
to point out that the real Salem Witch
Trials do differ a little bit from the
Salem Witch Trials depicted in Wizarding
World law for now we're going to be
looking at the real events and I'll jump
into the Harry Potter version of things
later in the video I digress no
discussion of which hands is complete
without delving Into the Dark Legacy of
the Salem Witch Trials which unfolded in
colonial America during the late 17th
century this tumultuous period saw a
fervent puritanical Society consumed by
fear as accusations of Witchcraft ran
rampant the trials resulted in the
tragic deaths of 20 innocent people
highlighting the devastating
consequences of unchecked Hysteria and
fanaticism
the Salem Witch Trials took place in the
town of Salem Massachusetts between 1692
and 1693. the trials were triggered by a
series of mysterious and unexplained
sieges fits and strange Behavior
exhibited by several young girls in the
community these girls including Betty
Paris and Abigail Williams claimed to
have been possessed by witches accusing
others in the community of possessing
Supernatural powers and consorting with
the Devil the trials were marked by lack
of due process and fairness the accused
were subjected to harsh interrogations
often leading to coerced confessions
those who did not confess were often
subjected to brutal forms of punishment
such as the infamous pressing method
where Stones were placed on the accused
body until they either confessed or died
under the weight the accused were
presumed guilty until proven innocent
and the burden of proof rested only
accused further stacking the odds
against them the hysteria and fear that
permeated the trials can be attributed
to multiple factors the rigid and
austere religious atmosphere of Puritan
New England created an environment where
any deviation from societal Norms was
seen as a threat the residents of Salem
believed in a spiritual realm filled
with malevolent forces and the fear of
Satan's influence lay heavy on their
shoulders the economic and social
tensions of the time also played a role
as the town of Salem was undergoing
rapid changes that bred unease and
instability one notable aspect of the
Salem Witch Trials was the prominence of
female accusers and accused the majority
of those accused were women who did not
conform to the strict expectations of
their Puritan Community whether through
their behavior reputation or
unconventional ideas this gendered
aspect of the trials reflects the power
dynamics and societal misogyny of the
time where women who did not conform to
the accepted Norms were seen as threats
to the established order the Salem Witch
Trials eventually reached a Tipping
Point when the respected Minister
increased Mather yes his name was really
increase along with other influential
figures in the colony expressed
skepticism and called for a more
cautious approach as the trials lost
credibility and public support waned the
prosecuting authorities disbanded the
court of Oya and termina the court
specifically established to hear
witchcraft cases the remaining accused
were then pardoned or released from
prison marking the end of The Witch Hunt
The Wizarding worlds witch hunts in the
Magical World of Harry Potter where
magic is abundant and Fantastic Beasts
roam we do find ourselves faced with a
dark shadow of History The Haunting
Specter of witch hunts given the
intrinsic nature of witches and wizards
in the Harry Potter story I suppose we
can't be too surprised that the two
worlds have collided on this aspect of
history but while the Witch Hunt in The
Wizarding World bear some similarities
to the real Witch Hunt of our own
history they also possess their own
unique twists and turns that set them
apart
similarities the first thing worth
mentioning is that the dates for witch
hunts in the real world directly
coincide with the dates in The Wizarding
World with both versions of these events
occurring roughly between the 14th and
18th century another key similarity
between the two is the atmosphere of
fear and paranoia surrounding those
accused of Witchcraft in both the real
and magical worlds accusations were
often based on rumors hearsay and
personal vendettas rather than concrete
evidence this led to a climate of
Suspicion where anyone could be targeted
and accused unjustly
furthermore both witch hunts involve
societal Prejudice and they desire to
eradicate those believed to possess
Supernatural powers in the real world
this was often fueled by religious
beliefs or fear of the unknown similarly
in The Wizarding World mughals had a
deep-seated fear and mistrust of wizards
and witches leading to their persecution
another similarity lies in the
consequences faced by those accused and
found guilty of Witchcraft in both cases
individuals suffered severe punishment
often including imprisonment torture and
execution the method of execution most
commonly referenced in Harry Potter law
is burning witches at the stake
differences now for the differences The
Wizarding world's account of the same
time period one of the first major and
rather amusing differences is that the
methods of torture utilized on witches
in The Wizarding World had a rather
different outcome you see in the
Wizarding World witches and wizards were
able to use magical means to escape the
lethal consequences of the Hunts one of
the best examples of this involved the
flame freezing charm which allowed
witches and wizards like Wendell in the
weird to survive burnings at the stake
in this regard which is burning at the
stake would feign screaming in pain
where in reality they were experiencing
a pleasant tickling sensation this would
allow them to successfully Escape
execution
non-magic people more commonly known as
Muggles were particularly afraid of
magic in medieval times but not very
good at recognizing it on the rare
occasion that they did catch a real
witch or wizard burning had no effect
whatsoever the witch or wizard would
perform a basic flame-pleasing charm and
then pretend to shriek with pain while
enjoying a gentle tickling sensation
indeed Wendell in the weird enjoyed
being burned so much that she allowed
herself to be caught no less than 47
times in various disguises one of the
next major differences was the response
of The Wizarding population two said
witch hunts in the real world as the
intensity of the witch hunts increased
hunted witches and wizards had no
alternative but to live in constant fear
and hide their true identities that was
all they could really do witches in The
Wizarding World on the other hand were
able to start living double lives using
concealment charms to protect themselves
this enabled them to establish their own
hidden communities within muggle
Villages ensuring their safety and
preserving their magical existence this
is referenced in Dumbledore's notes in
his copy of beetle The Bard's Wizard and
the hopping pots as the witch hunts grew
ever fiercer Wizarding families began to
live double lives using charms of
concealment to protect themselves and
their families by the 17th century any
witch or wizard who chose to fraternize
with Muggles became suspect even an
outcast in his or her own Community the
international statute of secrecy by the
17th century wizard muncle relations
were in Dire Straits the persecution of
witches and wizards had been on the rise
throughout Europe since the early 15th
century which caused many in The
Wizarding Community to feel a deep sense
of fear and danger and it was Wizarding
families who were particularly
vulnerable during this dark period as
their children who had not yet learned
to control their burgeoning magic would
inadvertently draw the attention of
muggle witch Hunters as such the
widespread persecution of young
Wizarding children was a grim reality in
this era Muggles continuously pressured
witches and wizards to perform magic for
their own ends attempting to wield their
powers for muggle purposes and even
demanding that they teach them magic the
number of witch burnings steadily
increased with even some Muggles being
mistakenly accused and unjustly burned
in Great Britain the newly formed
Ministry of magic desperately attempted
to establish communication with the
Mughal British Monarchy who at the time
was under the joint rule of William III
and Mary II the ministry special
delegation pleaded for the protection of
wizards under Mughal law seeking
official recognition for their magical
Brethren however the heartfelt appeals
of the British Ministry fell on deaf
ears the lack of response from the
British Monarchy seemed to be the final
straw that led wizard kind to choose a
different path a path shrouded in
secrecy hidden from Muggles and their
ever increasing hostility left with no
choice but the adoption of secrecy
wizard kind was forced to withdraw from
the world of Muggles retreating into
their own magical realm this in turn led
to the enactment of the international
statute of Wizarding secrecy a
protective measure that has enabled
Wizarding Society to remain in relative
peace for centuries the law was put in
place by the international Confederation
of wizards a Wizarding intergovernmental
organization that's roughly equivalent
to the United Nations in the Mughal
world this law first signed in 1689 and
officially ratified in 1692 was created
to conceal the existence of witches and
wizards from the Mughal population it
was designed to safeguard the magical
world through the implementation of
strict secrecy measures preventing
Muggles from discovering the existence
of The Wizarding community and their
magical ability abilities the statute
required all witches Wizards and magical
creatures of near human intelligence to
comply with the laws set forth by their
respective governing bodies such as the
ministry of magic in Britain or magical
Congress of the United States of America
each Wizarding governing body will be
responsible for the concealment care and
control of all magical beasts beings and
Spirits dwelling within its territory's
borders should any creature cause harm
to or Draw the notice of the Mughal
community that nation's Wizarding
governing body will be subject to
discipline by the international
Confederation of wizards when mingling
with Muggles Wizards and witches will
adopt an entirely muggle standard of
dress which will conform as closely as
possible to the fashion of the day
clothing must be appropriate to The
Climate the geographical region and the
occasion nothing self-altering or
adjusting is to be worn in front of
Muggles the introduction of the statute
ushered in an era of secrecy in and
separation between the Wizarding and
muggle worlds but while it offered
protection to witches and wizards it
also posed challenges and restrictions
on their interactions with Muggles it's
also worth noting that despite
establishing some semblance of Peace not
Every Witch and Wizard was entirely
satisfied with the solution opposition
as with any major law being passed in a
society the international statute of
secrecy was met with some degree of
opposition one of the loudest voices
belonged to a family we should all
already be quite familiar with the
malfoys at the time the malfoys were one
of the wealthiest and most influential
families in the magical community and
despite their professed belief in pure
blood values and Wizarding superiority
the Malfoy's had a surprising history of
associations with muggle Circles of
wealth and Status such as royalty and
aristocracy as you probably could have
guessed the Malfoy's love former local
treasures and Status overshadowed their
care for the greater magical communities
well-being as the law required all
magical folk to withdraw from local
Society it directly jeopardized the
Malfoy's place in the Highborn muggle
circles they so enjoyed as such they
initially fervently opposed the
enactment of the statute however once
the statute was ratified in 1692 the
malfoys abruptly changed their tune they
cut off all ties with Michael families
and transformed into vocal supporters of
the very law they had opposed however
there were other arguments against the
enactment of the statute there weren't
nearly as selfish many argued that by
separating the Two Worlds witches and
wizards denied themselves the
opportunity to positively influence and
shape Muckle attitudes towards magic it
was the opinion of many that
perpetuating a divide between the
magical and non-magical worlds would in
turn Foster ignorance and suspicion
others advocated for open dialogue
between witches Wizards and Muggles
emphasizing the importance of trust
education and understanding these
individuals believe that unifying the
magical and non-magical communities
would lead to more harmonious
coexistence eradicating fear and
promoting acceptance but I must say that
perspective does feel like a bit of a
pipe dream at least when applied to that
period in history furthermore throughout
history there have been instances of
witches and wizards who questioned the
oppressive nature of the international
statute of secrecy some argue that it
undermined the fundamental rights of
magical individuals by forcing them into
hiding and to denying them the freedom
to live openly as they truly were they
believed that by concealing their
abilities witches and wizards were
denying their own identity and
perpetuating a sense of self-shame and
secrecy but while the opposition to the
international statute of secrecy may not
have prevailed in altering its course
these dissenting voices do remind us of
the complex moral and ethical
considerations surrounding magical
secrecy I do sometimes wonder whether a
world built on openness and
understanding between magical and
non-magical individuals could have
achieved a different form of unity and
Harmony the Salem witch trials in Harry
Potter as you may have guessed the Salem
Witch Trials also made their way into
the World of Harry Potter in fact
although it's not explicitly stated the
year the international statute of
Wizarding secrecy was established is the
same year as the occurrence of the Salem
Witch Trials which surely can't just be
a coincidence the trials can be seen as
a catalyst for wizards and witches to go
into hiding ensuring their survival and
preventing further persecution this
Echoes the historical context where
witch hunts pushed the magical Community
to Desperate Measures such as concealing
their true identities or seeking refuge
in Hidden communities
furthermore the trials provoked many
witches and wizards who settled in the
new world to return to their homelands
and helped to dissuade further
immigration for centuries to come
especially by pure blood families though
witch hunts rarely ever caught actual
witches or Wizards their vicious nature
and widespread dispersal meant that
major Wizarding institutions such as
schools most notably Hogwarts and
ilvermorny and governments such as the
British Ministry and macusa were
established in highly remote places and
all concealed by powerful magical means
interestingly enough ilvermorny
otherwise known as American Hogwarts was
actually founded in Massachusetts the
same place that the trials took place
hidden in plain sight atop Mount
Greylock another notable difference
between real witch hunts and those
depicted in The Wizarding World is the
continued existence of witch hunting
into the 20th century in 1926 famed
manages to own Newt scamander
encountered a young girl in Sudan whose
magical abilities were discovered by
Muggles resulting in her imprisonment
this suggests that despite the magical
community's efforts to remain concealed
Witch Hunt still occurred in certain
regions and continued to pose a threat
to magical individuals
today the trials are remembered via full
Golden Phoenix statues that were erected
in the makusa headquarters in New York
City the power of fear during the height
of witch hunts fear became a potent
weapon in the hands of those seeking to
maintain social order and control
communities wrought with uncertainty and
hardship sought explanations for
Misfortune and tribulations turning to
the notion of Witchcraft as a convenient
scapegoat in times of crop failures
plagues infertility or natural disasters
individuals accused of Witchcraft were
blamed for these calamities serving as
sacrificial Lambs to soothe Collective
anxieties it is crucial to recognize the
role that manipulation Prejudice and the
exploitation of fear played in
perpetuating witch hunts the control
exerted by authorities and those in
power relied on the division and
paranoia fostered within communities the
repercussions of this manipulation
reverberated far beyond the lives of the
accused leaving lasting scars on the
collective psyche of societies
conclusion
Witch Hunt stand as harrowing reminders
of the depths Humanity can sink to when
consumed by fear ignorance and Prejudice
from their ancient Origins to the
notorious hunts in Europe and Beyond
these dark chapters in our history shape
the lives of countless individuals and
scarred societies as we remember the
victims of witch hunts let us commit to
learning from the past to stand against
discrimination and to foster a world
where compassion and understanding
Prevail over fear and hatred and that's
it for this video if you enjoy the
content please like the video and
subscribe to the channel until next time
remember differences of habit in
language are nothing at all if our aims
are identical and our hearts are open
thank you